Speaker 1: Let's start today with a very meaty,
substantial discussion about the American economy.
Inflation has reached its lowest annual level in
two years, and the right is coming up with new
ways to talk about how the economy is absolutely
terrible. And that's the question we're going
to address with real numbers today. I recently
reported to you on on Monday, in fact, Monday of
this week or three months ago. I don't remember.
No, it was two days ago. I told you about the
better than expected jobs numbers that came out
of April during the Biden administration. And I
hesitate to give too much credit or blame on these
issues in general to presidents because they have
to do with so many broader macroeconomic trends.
But everybody wants to make everything political.
But let's not get ahead of ourselves. Let's start
with inflation and then we'll move on from there.
Consumer prices in April rise at slowest
annual rate in two years. Reminder.
Often when we see the inflation numbers from
last month, they are actually the numbers for
the 12 month period ending last month. So in May,
we get the April 22 to April 23 numbers. In June,
we will get the May 22 to May 23 numbers. This is
like a trailing 12 month period, consumer prices
in April. This is Yahoo! Finance. Consumer prices
in April. April showed inflation pressures remain
elevated while headline prices rose at the slowest
annual rate since the period ending April 2021,
according to the latest data from the Bureau
of Labor Statistics, the Consumer Price Index
revealed headline inflation. Inflation rose 0.4%
over the last month and 4.9% over the prior year
in April. Now reminder, inflation has been very
high, as you can see here. This is a chart dating
back to 1970. We had this period culminating
in June of 2022 where inflation got very high,
as high as it's been going all the way back to
the early eighties and then exactly as predicted,
uncontroversial. It has been declining, declining,
declining. My prediction was, and there's nothing
special about me, I'm not patting myself on the
back. I'm not special in any way. Just the way
things were looking, getting an outlook of what
we were seeing, you know, in the used car market,
in the grocery store, in real estate, just looking
a little bit, being reasonable adults. Most of us,
some children in the audience, my
sense was by the end of this year,
we would be somewhere in the low fives, mid
fours, roughly when it comes to inflation,
which is still historically a little high, but
dramatically lower half of where we reached.
So that's happening. And of course you will.
You're already seeing right wingers saying,
David, these numbers are obviously fake. Have
you seen the price of eggs lately? And of course,
it's not just driven by the price of eggs. This
is a measure that we've talked about a number of
times. It's composed of a number of factors.
But let's now ask a broader question. If we
look at all of those different indicators that
I often tell you about, to answer the question,
is the economy doing well by traditional measures
which don't capture every aspect of the economy,
but they give us a picture what's going on with
inflation, How is GDP, where is unemployment,
how is consumer confidence? How's the stock market
doing? What about trade balance? You get a picture
that is quite unremarkable in the sense of things
are pretty much okay. Now, does that mean we don't
have inequality? No, we do. And we've had it
for a long time. Does this mean wages haven't
been keeping up with inflation? Absolutely. Going
back well beyond Joe Biden. But the picture is not
a very scary picture. You look at GDP, GDP in Q4
of 2022 was up 2.6% and in Q1 of this year was up
1.1%, 1.1%. Again, this is annualized. This isn't
an incredible number. We look for 2 to 3%, but
it's not a bad number either. We saw, of course,
this is a chart going back that includes the
pandemic. Q2 of 2020. We saw one of the largest
GDP decreases in in a very long time. We made a
lot of that back in Q3. And then the numbers have
just sort of been like, okay, at the beginning of
2022, we actually saw some negative GDP growth,
then more positive in Q3 and Q4 of last year and
then now a positive but not explosively exciting
numbers. So GDP is sort of like, okay, you look
at the unemployment rate and you see, of course,
this big spike here. This was the heart of COVID
of the pandemic. And since then, unemployment
has declined, declined, declined much of this
under President Joe Biden. How much credit we give
him depends on who you are. But be that as it is,
you see that the unemployment rate has now gotten
very low, as low as it got under Trump, as low as
it's been, quite frankly, dating all the way back
to the late 1960s. So unemployment is very low,
huh? Doesn't look like a disaster. We then look
at consumer confidence. Consumer confidence is
another indicator representing the confidence of
the average person in the American economy. And
you see that consumer confidence did decline a
little bit in April. Not much, but a little bit.
But it is historically at quite a high level.
Consumer confidence is a little bit below where it
was at the height of the stock market rally while
Trump was president. But it is historically quite
high. And you the chart is on the screen and sort
of the numbers speak for themselves. Well, what
about the stock market? These are S&P 500 returns
going all the way back to 1930. As you can see,
this very. Clearly shows the boom bust cycle of
the American economy. And as you can see here,
we had 2022 last year, a very bad year for the
stock market. 2021 was quite good. That was,
again, a year under Joe Biden. The S&P returning
27% in 2021, losing 19% in 2022. And so far this
year, the S&P 500 has returned more than 7% and
it's only meh. So really, no major red flag, big
scary data from the stock market either. Things
are pretty okay. And then lastly, you look at
the trade balance, which many folks on the right
often like to discuss, important to understand.
So trade balance means how much are we exporting
versus how much are we importing. The U.S. has
had consistent trade deficits for a long time.
This chart, let's see if we can go back further.
Um, there we go. So if you go back to the mid
seventies, the U.S. has had high trade deficits,
and this is because we import a bunch of oil
and consumer products and consumer products.
More recently, oil has not been the source of the
trade deficit that applies under Trump and Biden,
even though Trump likes to pretend that it was
only under Trump that we weren't having a deficit
on oil. But it's under Biden as well. And as you
can see, if we look more recently, since early
2022, the trade deficit has been declining. So,
again, a situation that is much bigger than Biden,
but nothing hugely concerning. So what is the
big picture with the economy? The big picture
with the economy is that stepping outside of the
political realm without assigning credit or blame
to Joe Biden or Kamala Harris or Donald Trump or
Mike Pence, We just take a 20 year view and we
look at what happened under Trump and what's
been happening under Biden. And it is really
difficult to make the statistical case that we
are in a disastrous economy today. Could a major
recession be coming? Of course, that's a reality
of the type of capitalist economy in which we
live. That was true under Bush, Obama, Trump and
Biden. But are we in a disastrously perilous place
right now that we can point to when it comes
to any of these indicators? The answer is no